qu'il a dit il y a un truc qui ne prend
pas something dysent correspond il y a
un truc qui prend pas c'est un acteur
très connu un acteur un Américain
Philippe je veux la réponse c'est non
pas un Américain français
acteur un acteur français un acteur
français ah c'est beau gosse qui est
cette Lanvin non il sort avec une copine
à toi il sera vide
tu la connais bien sûr et sympa ça
dépend des jours
quand tu as dit ça sur Karine Lemarchand
il y avait marqué Yahoo Philippe
Candeloro Karine Le Marchand attaque ça
dépend des jours elle est odieuse
Noctali est très bien mais quand elle
était présente de la Fédération
française des sports de glace elle était
devenue un peu moins en fait parfois le
statut en les gens
exactement dès qu'on met une veste ce
soir pour le patron
c'est à vous de sa carrière
internationale aux États-Unis il
reconnaît que c'est un échec et un truc
qui a pas pris
on vous appelle d'ici dans trois
semaines je mets en trois semaines moi
parce que moi j'ai ma vie j'ai du boulot
j'ai des trucs à faire enfin j'aurais pu
travailler un peu l'anglais j'aurais pu
me forcer un peu j'aurais pu ça m'aurait
peut-être plus mais le fait que j'adore
jouer dans ma langue j'ai l'impression
que j'ai pas tout fait encore il y a des
choses à expérimenter ici accessoirement
j'ai une famille
je et c'est vrai culturellement je me
sens pas super bien là-bas j'ai un il y
a un truc qui prend pas quoi j'adore les
regarder comme ça mais non ça marche pas
[Applaudissements]
Maurice Chevalier il y en a qui sont aux
États-Unis ça marche pas à part parler
le joueur le petit français même Omar Sy
quand il a fait Jurassic Park et tout ça
il a un tout petit rôle si tu es pas
bilingue et tout ça
qui parlait mais non c'est pas dinosaure
qui parlait c'était il parle mais plus
que lui que lui parler
les Américains chez nous dans nos films
français ne marche pas forcément il s'en
foutent ça ça tombe qu'en France film
français moyen c'est 7 millions d'euros
États-Unis c'est 120 alors on peut dire
que ça tape un petit peu de nous hein
voilà ils appellent ça Josephine ange
gardien Philippe tu l'as rencontré Jean
Dujardin oui deux fois
jamais été invité à la maison vous avez
fait quoi du jardin mais non c'est quand
il commençait avec Nathalie on s'est vu
une fois Courchevel on a faim quand même
sympa manger une fondue non juste
partager un moment sympathique en boîte
et un gars très simple voilà en boîte en
boîte c'est bon la gueule il a vomi
était très sobre très bien c'est vrai
mais une dernière il pleurait misère et
puis là il nous dit qu'il était à
Courchevel avec du jardin
[Musique]
c'est bien connu des séminaires c'est
toujours un Courchevel et jamais à Melun
il y a très peu de filles des séminaires
on peut réagir à ce qu'il a dit ou pas
parce que en cœur tu es payé pour ça une
fortune parce que il nous prend non mais
il nous prend un petit peu pour un petit
peu pour des trompettes parce qu'en fait
après
the artistes 2014 il joue dans monument
de semaine qui a un gros film américain
avec notamment Clooney etc et sa
prestation a pas été particulièrement
comment dire remarquer apprécié par la
par la presse US et parler par les
critiques sur place donc depuis il a pas
forcément eu les propositions qui
auraient été dans son créneau comme a eu
Omar Sy lui qui était dans un autre
créneau mais il les a eus et ça a
fonctionné pour lui donc Jean Dujardin
je pense qu'il aurait pu te rendre
compte dans un pays repartir dans un
pays où personne Gad Elmaleh génial et
vraiment bravo Gad c'est super drôle son
one man mais tu es connu dans un pays tu
es une star tu vas là-bas sur c'est un
casting devant 50 personnes qu'au 24 ans
tu fais un pas pour te présenter c'est
hyper dur
alors moi c'est souvent mais là pas du
tout franchement non franchement Jean
Dujardin honnêtement il est allé là-bas
et ça ne lui a pas plu ni de tourner en
anglais ni de donc c'est pas eux qui ont
pas voulu lui c'est lui qui quelque part
là-bas
oui oui parce que ce mec m'intéresse et
je suis depuis
un choses à faire pour lancer oui je
pense qu'il l'a su que je le sais juste
c'est ce qu'il dit en interview
et il dit justement et je trouve dommage
que les Français n'aiment pas davantage
la France et ben moi c'est un discours
auquel je suis resté
avec George Clooney il est content quand
même
il préfère Paris les poubelles à Los
Angeles le soleil